so how many of you guys like racing
games man i'm sure there's quite a bit
of you that enjoy a good racing game i'm
not one of them if you want to get
technical i don't really mess with
racing games at all but i've been told
by countless people in the podcast in
the internet in general attic you got to
try force horizon it's one of those
games that really rewards casual play on
people that don't normally play racing
type games so here i am reviewing forza
horizon 5 and i'm going to be reviewing
this on the standpoint that i don't play
racer games if you're expecting a racing
type of review don't expect this here
this is someone that doesn't normally
play racing games whatsoever reviewing
forza horizon 5 for the xbox series x
let's get on with it but before we get
on with the video definitely follow the
iron lords podcast every sunday at 1 p.m
and at 11 am when there's football going
on but without any further ado let's
review forza horizon 5 for the xbox
series x
[Music]
what's going you guys lord attitude
coming at you for another review today
we're going to be reviewing forza
horizon 5. for those of you that's been
following the podcast you know that when
it comes to forza horizon or really any
racer in general i've always been one of
the gamers that never really resonated
with the racing genre besides the need
for speed most wanteds i've really
enjoyed those type of games and you know
for the most part you got to put some
kind of cop racing thing in there or cop
chasing thing before i really want to
try these type of racing games out and
for the most part the only real forza
game i have played is forza horizon 2.
sure forza horizon 3 and 4 is a horizon
4. i might pop in and you know see how
good the game looks i remember when the
series x came out one of the first games
i played was a forza horizon for a whole
three to four minutes and i turned that
sucker right off i can honestly say i've
never formally given a forza horizon
game enough time to really find out if i
like this type of franchise or not
because i've never really connected to
the racing genre in general but
microsoft sent the iron lore's podcast
they sent us a review copy for forza
horizon 5 and we felt like this is the
perfect time for me to really try this
brand and to see exactly how i like it
and well i actually have to say i'm very
surprised now let's talk about the
graphics of this game first forza
horizon 5 is actually pretty gorgeous
like i do play it on the xbox series x i
do not know what condition this game
looks over on the original xbox or the
big bulky xbox but when over here on the
xbox series x and i'm assuming on the pc
the game is gorgeous it's in mexico and
you can really feel the world just alive
on here i do wish that there was a
little bit more in terms of stuff going
on you know a little bit more to
actually make it seem like mexico is
alive and not necessarily just a
playground for you to play and i would
have liked a little bit more traffic
going into this game now is there
traffic in this game yes there is
definitely traffic in this game but i
felt like they could have did a little
bit different maybe it's because it is a
cross generation game and to my
knowledge it is on the older system so
you know having that kind of outdated
hardware that playground games had to
work around i can understand why there
were some limitations from the ground
floor in terms of how they were making
forza horizon 5. but i feel like when
they make another forza horizon
regardless wherever it is i know a lot
of people wanted to be in japan let's
have a little bit more of a world that's
alive now i'm not saying this world
wasn't alive to a point but i do feel
like they can do better on this where i
want to drive through these areas and i
want to see a lot of cars i want to see
lots of animals going around are you
sure you saw some of that in here but i
felt like if it was in that actual area
in real life you would see a lot more of
it than you saw in this game clearly
it's a video game i understand that i
understand to a point it's not really
about the wildlife or about the traffic
going around it's about the racing and
the environment and actually using these
cars in this playground that they've
made and as far as mexico keep in mind i
have never been to mexico but what i see
here if mexico is anything like this and
what i've been told playground games is
a really good job at capturing the
aspect of the world that they built for
the forza horizon franchise they did a
really good job in this you know like i
said i've never been to mexico but it
makes me actually want to visit these
places see what i'm racing through see
the towns that you're racing to i like
when you're doing some of the races in
forza horizon 5 where you're trying to
drift around the corners of a city or a
town i do think this is one of the
aspects of the game that i enjoy the
most where you feel like you're actually
in the fast and the furious movie
back in the day not now obviously now
it's not fast and the furious but you
guys get the point and you know it
really shows you that playground games
has a real good pulse on how to make
different types of the map you got the
desert area you got the forest air the
swamp area you got the just wide open
areas you got the city areas you got the
town areas the thing that is really nice
that about forza horizon 5 is that they
were able to make all of these different
parts of the map seem unique in its own
different way when you're doing some of
the races that put you around the entire
map yes i said the entire map these
races generally take 20 to 20 to 30
minutes long to complete them they
really give you a good sensation of how
well this map has been made and how good
this map is keep in mind some of the
races are actually around mountaintops
there's a huge mountain in this game
where there's a lot of times when you do
a race around that mountain you're going
through that mountain you're going up
and then you're going down and you're
going through it in general and i've
really enjoyed the diversity in terms of
of the races because there is races for
anything you can think of in this game
you have the off-road races you have the
street races the country races there is
a lot of different things for everyone
here ensures people such as myself
doesn't normally play these type of
racing games it's really nice that they
give you the option to do anything you
really want to i personally enjoyed the
off-road races i felt like those were
really put well together and they really
satisfied my sensation to race in this
game i enjoyed some of the drag racing
thing that goes on this i do feel like
they could have made an actual drag
racing playlist for the most part it
looked like just speed traps around the
map now i might be wrong about that
because i did go to a few of them it
just felt like it was more about speed
trap than you know the old need for
speed where you would manually shift up
in the game to actually get to the end
of the finish line you know you guys
remember those old need for speeds where
you can actually hit a random car that
comes out of nowhere i kind of wanted
that in this game to a point but i can
understand why you know that type of
gameplay isn't what they're really
highlighting here especially in a
country like mexico they want to really
highlight those cities the towns the
hills the you know the desert in general
they want to highlight more of that
aspect than just a long stretch of road
that you just manually switch shifts in
and i can really respect that just next
time playground games man make it a
little bit more of an event when you do
a drag race i want to actually have that
type of experience that i enjoyed in
those older need for speeds remember i'm
a casual person when it comes to the
racing genre i can only really give you
opinions on stuff that i've played in
the past such as the need for speed most
wanted need for speed underground and a
lot of those type of game modes were in
that game so i would really appreciate
it if you breathe some of that over here
especially the car cop chasing scenario
that goes on in the older games such as
need for speed let's have some of that
in this game i understand a lot of
people don't want that to be the core
focus of forza horizon
but a lot of these game modes isn't the
for focus but you could still have them
on here and be very transparent in how
you want this to be you don't have to
make it all about cop chasing but i do
feel like a lot of people would enjoy
that type of game play in this game and
i think forza horizon the next one have
some type of mode where you can actually
drive around and engage in some kind of
cop chases because i feel like people
such as myself will automatically have
flashbacks to the old days when we used
to play the need for speed games and
we'll really adapt to these these newer
games a lot better because we have that
experience in this newer game let's talk
about the performance real quick now for
the most part the performance of forza
horizon 5 during the entire time i
played it i probably played it for a
good 25 to 35 hours i'm still playing it
now but you know i definitely wanted to
make sure i got this review out to you
guys and give you guys my opinion on the
game in general but i didn't really have
a whole lot of issues sure there was
some hiccups in certain scenarios that i
would have but i don't think anything
that happened in terms of playing this
game was enough to make me really think
it would impact anyone's time with forza
horizon 5. i felt like playground games
did a very good job optimizing this for
the xbox series x now i cannot speak for
the pc version because i know there are
always sometimes issues on the pc that's
why i don't really game on the pc a
whole whole lot but as far as the xbox
series x i don't know about the s but
the x it was a very good sensation on
how i played this game now there were a
little bit internet connectivity issues
when i would try to join up with other
people that had the game and i would try
to do a little bit more of the co-op
experiences and the pvp experiences when
it comes to the online features that's
in this game keep in mind you can co-op
race with your friends you can actually
pretty much pvp race with your friends
it's got a lot of aspects in terms of
how the actual online infrastructure
works you can have your own little mini
custom games and there's actual an
elimination thing on here that you can
do as well i'm really enjoying the fact
that they are giving you a lot more in
terms of social aspects in these racing
games to really bring people together to
play more of this game as a group and i
think at the end of the day sure playing
really immersive single-player games is
is probably a very good highlight in
terms of gaming in general but i've
always had the most fun with games if i
can actually enjoy it with a friend or
two and i think that for the most part
of what i played on this i did play a
few of these co-op sessions it was
actually a lot funner with other people
and i would recommend you know trying
that out i'm pretty sure most likely
they're going to get the server issues
handled i didn't see a huge issue i was
able to connect to people just fine it's
just sometimes they would drop off out
of nowhere for some reason but it's like
i said
in terms of performance i will say forza
horizon didn't really give me a whole
lot of issues now i can only speak for
myself i don't know if other people have
more issues because i know when it comes
to performance it changes from if you're
on a pc changes what type of game you're
playing what kind of game mode maybe
there's a bug that happens on one
reviewer but not the other but in terms
of myself i had a good experience sure
there was a couple hiccups but it was
nothing drastic enough to make me think
it would impact any of your guys's
experience playing this game now clearly
this is a racing type of game so we're
gonna have a lot of races in this game
what i really enjoyed about this that i
know they've had in previous fours but i
never really got to experience a whole
lot of them because i didn't really play
any of the old forces is the showcases
in this game you'll be racing a plane
and then you'll be raising ski jets
these showcases in the game i would say
some of the highlights of forza horizon
5. it gives you that sensation that
you're right on their neck and it can be
head-to-head all the way up to the very
end and a lot of these showcases it was
neck to neck into the variant and you
barely come through at the very end and
get that w and it gives you a lot of
winning sensation that you actually
accomplished something because it was a
rough race now i will say it does look
like it doesn't really seem to be that
you can actually get ahead of some of
these objects that you race in these
showcases but it does seem like you know
it is always set to make it to where it
feels like you are always head-to-head
with these objects and you know racing a
plane how could you really realistically
beat a plane in a race but i do like the
way they set it up to where it feels
like you're on the edge of your seat the
entire time you're doing these events
and you know speaking of events they
actually have these
certain big races that you can do in
every area and every aspect of every
type of event you can do where it pretty
much is that event that you've been
racing with regardless if it's offline
roading or street racing but they it's
that pretty much grand prix it's
whatever
that highest level of thing that you can
race in that and every one of them seems
to have one like i was mentioning
earlier there is one that literally
takes you around the entire map and it
took me about 15 to 20 minutes to do the
off-road one was a very good experience
as well and that took me about 20 to 25
minutes sure some of these feel like
they're a little bit dragged out and
maybe pull them back a little bit for
future installments in my opinion
obviously i'm not really a huge racer so
i can understand if a lot of the other
gamers that love these type of games
like that but to me it did feel a little
bit just drawn out like by the time i
finished some of these races i was done
i wanted to turn off forza horizon it
didn't necessarily you know mean it was
a bad thing it just meant like i felt
like i was racing forever and sure it
was really good of experience in terms
of doing some of these races where it
took you around the whole map it was fun
doing it one time but after doing it
more than one time it kind of felt a
little bit redundant because i felt like
i would race around the map and i was
you know really taking in all the
aspects that this mexico map that
playground games has designed and built
in forza horizon 5. but by the time you
go around the whole map one time you
don't really in particular my case don't
want to do those long long races a lot
but keep in mind to my knowledge and
what i played at the game and i played a
lot of the game it did not seem like
those races was a lot of them it did
seem like they were in this and it
seemed like there was one for every type
of race that you can get but it didn't
seem like it was a lot of them and i'm
not saying that more of them would have
been an issue i'm not saying less of
them would have been an issue i'm saying
that when i did one i really dreaded
doing the other ones because it's not
necessarily on if i could do it or not
do it i was just dreading the amount of
time it took to do those races because
it was such a long distance that you had
to race the other drivers now clearly we
got to talk about the cars man we got to
talk about the cars because this is a
forza horizon game there's a lot of cars
and i can't tell you about really any of
them not really a racing kind of person
i'm not really a car person in general i
picked the porsche and i picked the
porsche because in need for speed most
wanted i want to pour off a blacklist
member and until this day that's the
kind of car i want to drive sure was
there a lot of different options here
you get cars for just about anything i
didn't buy a lot of cars in this game
there were some i did buy but for the
most part you just win cars you win
massive amounts of cars you do anything
you win cars you do any type of skills
any type of achievements that's in the
game you win cars so they always are
able to give you something new to drive
and if you're a real big car maniac like
as some of my friends are i'm sure
you're going to spend hours in there
designing your own designs making the
cars look good they have a huge social
aspect in this game to where you can
make your design and they'll actually
give it to other people and let them
download it and actually write you if
you like that design or not and i think
that's a really good aspect once again
with the social aspect now let's talk a
little bit about the customization
and your avatars and stuff i felt like
they could improve on this not everyone
dresses the same and i went through an
entire page it was literally almost the
exact same type of clothes just slightly
altered and i'm not saying
that there isn't stuff you can unlock
because throughout the game you do
unlock stuff you unlock horns you unlock
you know emotes but when it comes to the
customization and how you look i feel
like the industry in general needs to be
better on this everyone dresses
differently that people like to voice
their expression in the way they look
and if you don't give people the options
to do this effectively you're gonna see
a lot of people get upset in terms of
how you look in this game did it bother
me not really because i didn't really
pay attention to the look of my actual
avatar in the game because to me this
game's more about the racing than
anything else it's not really about the
avatar but i do want to mention to you
guys that if you're a huge customization
person there is a lot of customization
that you can get in this game there's a
lot that you can unlock in this game
there's a lot that you keep at the gate
in this game but i do feel like they
need more variety and more diversity in
terms of the type of clothes that you
can buy in this game but anyway that's
the review on forza horizon 5 man like i
felt like this is a solid experience i
would give it the iron lords podcast
still it's definitely worth downloading
on game pass and even buying it for full
price on the store i think it's a very
effective game looks very good has a lot
of social aspects that you can play this
with your friends for a long time and
it's got great gameplay it's got great
races that you can do there's a lot of
stuff to do here in terms of content
content's king and forza horizon 5 has a
lot of content and i think the majority
of people that even have a remote like
in terms of the racing genre maybe not
people like such as myself because i'm
kind of on that edge to where i don't
need to play racing games i play racing
games when they appeal to me and when my
friends want me to play and for the most
part everyone on the iron lures podcast
everyone in the comments section
everyone in the community always told me
attic you got to try the forza horizon
games and i tried it and i can honestly
say
it definitely gave me the sensations
that i wanted and i recommend it to
everyone that's watching this video go
out there try it out man it's a very
good game but anyway that's for the
review man definitely put in the comment
section below how you feel about forza
horizon 5 is this something that you
guys are excited about until next time
this is lord addict i'm outta here peace